ne pas qu'ils disent n'est pas en partie
et biologiques et régis l'action sur
l'économie contre le transport de 4 brut
agir contre les gaz à effet de serre
nous sommes vraiment dans la récession
ce n'est pas technique c'est la réalité
nous entamons notre série d'entrevues
avec les chefs des partis fédéraux avec
ce soir elizabeth may la chef du parti
vert la première candidate de cette
formation à être élu à la chambre des
communes
elle dénonce stephen harper pour son
bilan en matière d'environnement et
qualifie elle aussi de faux débat celui
entourant le niqab
j'ai rencontré un peu plus tôt
aujourd'hui madame et bonjour bonjour
madame claire de peau mais là mais vous
savez vous êtes très apprécié vous êtes
même c'est vous qui avez le plus la
confiance des participants à notre
boussole électorale
ex aequo avec le chef du npd thomas
mulcair
et pourtant votre parti n'arrive pas à
avoir plus que 5 6 % d'appuis pourquoi
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qui vous empêche
de faire une percée
nous avons augmenté le niveau d'appui
mais c'est dans les régions locales au
niveau national c'est vraiment difficile
de fait les bons sondages plus de 6 à 6
7%
mais est-ce que c'est pas le fait qu'il
ya d'autres partis maintenant qu'ils
défendent aussi l'environnement
chaque partie enfin je pense aux
libéraux néo-démocrates au bloc ont une
plateforme environnementale
ça vient un peu vous couper l'herbe sous
le pied non non malheureusement l'autre
partie seulement les les plateformes
très faible et c'est seulement le bloc
québécois qui sont d'accord avec le
parti vert contre les pipelines
qu'aménager ah c'est vrai mais et c'est
un grand avantage d'avoir les députés
verts ton agent technique pour le québec
et pour les québécoises et québécois
parce que nous sommes à partie avec les
députés dans les autres provinces aussi
et qu'on en a
était absolument engager pour arrêter
ces piscines pour pour arrêter le
croissance de sables bitumineux c'est
nécessaire de mettre sur pied un
stratégie énergétique nationale
et vous pensez que c'est mieux pour les
environnementalistes d'être dans un
parti vert comme le vôtre qui n'aspire
pas à prendre le pouvoir que d'être dans
un parti qui justement peut peut-être
gouverner c'est comme si vous étiez
postes sur la patinoire vous êtes à côté
de la patinoire notre propos nous nous
pensons maintenant c'est le moment de
pure c'est parce que actuellement nous
avons les sondages qui indiquent un
parlement minoritaire et dans un
parlement minoritaire les partis verts
et les députés verts ont le pouvoir de
fait les grands changements
peut-être peut-être nous allons avoir le
bal ans de pouvoir avec les capitales
oui c'est pas si c'est monsieur harper
qui obtient un gouvernement minoritaire
vous avez déjà dit que vous et vous
aimeriez voir le gouverneur général pour
lui dire de ne pas lui permettre de
former le gouvernement mais est ce que
c'est possible c'est vraiment possible
parce que dans notre système
parlementaire
mais j'ai appris à le première essai
mais ce n'est pas clair que si j'avais
l'effort de parler avec le gouverneur
général et aussi avec les autres chefs
des autres partis
le moc rm je trouve l'eau est dit que 21
minutes s'il vous plaît donnez nous
comme un groupe de députés un groupe de
chefs des autres partis
l'occasion de parler l'un l'autre pour
trouver s'il est possible de travailler
ensemble travailler pour trouver une
façon de travailler ensemble comme pas
vraiment comment collection officielle
c'est possible mais pour trouver
pas un parlement de rab le stade plus
efficace et pourquoi vous ne donnerez
pas une chance à monsieur harper
d'essayer au moins de gouverner c'est un
décennie de destruction avec monsieur
après la destruction de nos lois pour la
protection d'environnement destruction
de notre approche pour les justice
criminelle pour justice sociaux cds park
70 d'imaginer un autre minutes avec
monsieur rappeur compris nous ici on est
comme nous engager pour la protection
d'environnement et pour les négociations
à paris qui sont le début des
négociations à paris elle sera seulement
40 jours après les élections
nous n'avons pas ne veut pas le temps
pour mes joueurs pour faire les essais
ans dont le parent allemand avec le
gouvernement minoritaire mais c'est
essentiel pour le canada de prendre aux
traditionnelles des leaders dans le
monde et quel est le parti dont vous
êtes le plus proche alors quel est le
parti qui a la meilleure plateforme
environnementale pour vous pour tous les
autres sont faibles c'est vrai tous les
autres sont meilleurs de monsieur rap
c'est je pense que c'est aller après les
élections on regarde tous les députés
aient pensé en négociation avec les
autres c'est monsieur trudeau où
monsieur moquer pour moi c'est fait pas
de faire travailler avec lui doit
absolument je vais vous poser une
question sur le port du niqab
oui parce que vous savez que c'est en
train de dominer tout le débat de cette
campagne électorale depuis plusieurs
jours donc le parti vert est d'accord ou
contre le port du niqab lors des
cérémonies d'assermentation oui c'est un
faux débat ça c'est vraiment fou parce
que et il ya eu qu une enfance de
prendre l'engagement citoyen a un visage
couvert sais pas c'est pas
c'est pas un tour pas du tout et ce
n'est pas aux hommes de décider ce que
les femmes doivent porter ou pensez vous
décider je pense que c'est un faux débat
et j'espère que on peut parler des
sujets importants comme chose saute
climatique comme l'arrestation de
l'évadé chose de très symbolique quand
même oui dans une cérémonie
d'assermentation quand on devient
citoyen canadien il n'y a pas de
bénéfice pour quelqu'un qui qui était
avec un visage couvert qu'est ce que
c'est qu'est ce que c'est le problème
avec ça je comprends pas pourquoi c'est
mais c'est avec le cynisme de monsieur
harper avec son cap il était de créer
les débats avec beaucoup aimé aussi
émotion et de peur
l'un contre l'autre c'est une opération
politique parce que monsieur rappeuse se
présente comme un défenseur des femmes
où ils en sont mais ce n'est pas pour
lui et pour décider de ce que les femmes
doivent porter mieux rares percées n'est
pas il n'est pas quelqu'un qui a fait le
grand lutte pour les droits des femmes
au contraire autour du canada nous avons
l'équipe des questions de violence
contre les femmes mais je rai uno rai le
demande d'avoir un mec est pour les
femmes autochtones qui sont m alors
s'est il n'est pas quelqu'un féministes
pour protéger les droits des femmes le
franchement merci beaucoup madame et
merci